Dan Co makes $5 million a year with
nothing other than a keyboard. But when
he self-published his non-fiction book,
The Art of Focus, it really hurt his
personal brand. Why? Because writing
that fails to deliver clear value for
your readers becomes a disaster for your
credibility. So today, I'm roasting Dan
Co's writing mistakes so that you don't
have to repeat them. And I'm going to
share four strategies that I use to help
my clients write authoritybuilding books
without pissing off their audience
because the last thing you want is
reviews like this. If someone asked me
to describe what the book is about, I
would have great difficulty explaining
it. It was just too disjointed. I agree
with others that suggested he should
have had an editor. The lack of an
editor really shows. I found the writing
quality to be distractingly poor,
atrocious, and sophomoric. I think Dan
has a lot of amazing ideas, so it's a
real shame that the book is just so bad.
I love Dan Co, but man, get a good
editor. Self-publishing is not a good
idea. This is a disorganized collection
of platitudes and superficial spiritual
reflections. Now, to be clear, I love
Dan and his message, and I respect his
work. So, this roast is coming from a
place of love, and I want this to be
useful to anyone who's thinking about
writing a non-fiction book as part of
their oneperson business model. It's
worthwhile to write a book. They can be
a tremendous asset in your business. But
the thing that many firsttime authors
like Dan don't realize is that there's a
big difference between the genres of
social media, like tweets, scripts, and
sales pages, and the genre of a
non-fiction book. They require different
conventions and different language
choices. So, I was initially tipped off
about the issues in this book by one of
my clients who told me that they don't
want to write a book like Dan Co because
his feels like a bunch of tweets. And
when I heard that, I knew that I needed
to make this video because genre is a
really important concept for firsttime
writers to understand. And once they get
it, they stop making mistakes like Dan
Co. So, I read dozens of reviews to find
the real issues in this book. And for
the sake of fairness, I ignored the
onestar rants and just focused on the
two or three star reviews. And those
generally came from fans of Dan who
really wanted to like the book, but they
still felt let down. And through all
these reviews, there were four big
issues that kept popping up. And the
first one is right there in the title.
But don't just take it from me. Here's
one of the reviews that totally nails
this point. Lots of cool topics, but
each gets one short paragraph and almost
no practical depth. So, if you clicked
on a video titled How to Write a
Best-selling Business Book, and a few
seconds into it, I start going into a
deep dive on breath work, well, you
would obviously click away. We call that
clickbait, right? And that's what's
happening here in Dan's book. Look at
the full title. He calls it a practical
philosophy to find meaning, reinvent
yourself and create your ideal future.
That word practical, it's really
important. Okay, practical means that
you are going to give stepbystep help,
something that people can practice. Yet,
take a look at the table of contents. Do
these chapter titles signal to you
anything about something that you can
practice? We've got the new rich, the
self, the game, the lens. None of these
chapter titles tell the reader what
they're going to learn or be able to do.
The promise and the content don't line
up, so readers lose trust before they
even get to the first page. So, a simple
fix for this is to name your chapters as
the promise of that chapter. So each
chapter name should deliver a clear
takeaway that moves the main idea
forward. You can't write a book about
practical philosophy and then fill the
table of contents with vague
abstractions or inside references that
they only get after reading the chapter.
If the book is indeed practical, then
you should be able to tell the reader
what problem that chapter solves. that
is by the end of this chapter, what will
the reader be able to do or what new
idea will they take in and what old idea
will it replace? And so to get really
concrete about this, I like to have my
clients think about their ideas as the
solution to a problem. And whenever they
do that, they tend to find that there
are these two kinds of problems. If it's
a practical problem, it's something that
you can solve by changing your actions.
But on the other hand, you know, not
every book is a step-by-step guide of of
what to do. Um, sometimes we are just
working in the world of ideas. Now,
ultimately those ideas are upstream of
behaviors that we want to change. So,
once we have a better understanding of
whatever it might be, climate change,
well, ultimately that better
understanding is going to tell us how to
change our behavior. So, at the end of
the day, conceptual problems are still
linked to practical problems. But
nevertheless, if you're working with
concepts and you're not really getting
into behavior, well, still there is an
action that the reader can take and that
is to replace one old idea with a new
idea. In this genre of prescriptive
non-fiction, right, practical guides to
problem solving, what you want to do is
fill your table of contents with
promises to the reader of what they will
learn and be able to do after reading
this chapter. All right. So, my
recommendation here would be to turn
these vague titles into learning goals.
So, for example, in this chapter on the
new rich, right? That's a cool chapter.
You're talking about this new economy,
people who are making their money by
sharing value online or something like
that. Well, you need to tell readers
what idea that this this idea of the new
rich, what idea does that replace? All
right. So, in this chapter on the new
rich, I I read through it closely and I
tried to find what is the central idea
here that he wants the reader to take
away. And I've got to admit it was kind
of hard to find, but I think I found it
over here in the last paragraph. And I
think a good chapter title for for this
chapter would be design your life around
stillness, not status. Right? If you
have that in the table of contents and
at the top of the the page in the
chapter, that tells the reader what
they're getting into. Right now, they
can decide whether they want to dive
into this, not these abstract riddles
and vague noun phrases at the top. The
new rich doesn't tell the reader
anything about what you expect them to
take away from this chapter. But with
takeaways in the table of contents, the
reader knows what they're going to get
and why it matters. So if you're writing
a book like this, then just ask of every
chapter, what will the reader do or what
new idea will the reader learn? So
ultimately, what we're trying to do here
is to reframe our understanding of a
chapter. A chapter doesn't give readers
ideas. A chapter makes a promise to the
reader. It says, "You're very busy. You
can be giving your attention to 500
other things, but if you pay attention
to this chapter, here's what I promise
you. And if readers are interested in
that promise, then they'll be very happy
to trade you their attention for that
value. All right. Now, the second issue
that kept coming up with Dan Co's book
was related to the purpose of the book.
So, one reviewer said, "I'm a fan of Dan
Co's Twitter and Instagram, so I was
excited to read his book, but a few
pages in, I was already bored. This book
about focus couldn't keep my focus. Next
time, skip the fluff and get right to
the meat and potatoes. Returning
unfortunately, that's a little harsh,
but there were plenty of reviews that
sounded just like that. A book on focus
that lost its readers focus. Fate loves
irony. So, why did these readers quit?
Well, an important thing to understand
here is that readers don't owe us their
attention. This is actually a really bad
habit that I think my lot professors and
and English teachers have instilled in
writers, right? Students don't have to
earn the attention of their reader.
That's their teacher. We get paid by the
school and we have to sit here and read
your essays and reports. So, if that's
the place where you've cut your teeth
writing, we kind of forget that when we
are trying to build an audience with our
writing, those readers really don't owe
us their attention. And this is obvious
whenever it comes to things like
Instagram and you know these other
platforms. But somehow we forget it. We
think you know I put so much effort into
this piece that surely the reader is is
is going to have to read it. We writers
have to earn the attention of readers by
giving clear value on every page. Value.
That's the key word here. We have to
deliver value. And so when people say
they felt bored with Dan's book or it
couldn't hold their attention, that's
what they're talking about. And even if
the book is filled with value, that's
not the problem. I'm not saying Dan Co
does not deliver value to his readers
and to his audience. What I'm saying is
that his readers could not perceive that
value. And that's because of the way
that the book was written and the way
the ideas were positioned. Even people
who finished the book said they
regretted the time they spent. One
reviewer wrote, "This book added nothing
to my life even though I wanted it to."
So, the key to sustaining attention is
to deliver value. And of course, we all
talk about value here on business
YouTube, but in the world of writing, I
really mean something specific. And
we're going to get to that. But here's
another reviewer who asked, "What does
this have to do with focus, persuasive
writing, or entrepreneurship?" And
that's a great question because this
book makes that promise, but it never
delivers. So Dan Co's audience shows up
again and again to his YouTube and his
Instagram posts for business and
personal branding advice. Now, as
interested as he might be in
spirituality, I think Dan Co might have
been a Mormon or he had some kind of
spiritual journey before he got into
this world of um personal branding. But
nevertheless, as interested as he might
be in that, that has nothing to do with
his content and therefore nothing to do
with his audience. So when the ideas in
a book don't match the purpose that the
reader brought to the book, that's when
you break their trust and the book goes
straight into the trash. How to fix it?
Well, the steps that I recommend at the
very start of a book project is actually
to get away from the book, to get away
from the writing, to get away from the
ideas that you want to put in it. even
to get away from the reader. I like to
sit with the writer at the beginning of
the process and ask what's your goal for
this book. Like writing a book is
obviously hard. It takes a lot of time
and you know it's a big project. So what
is your definition of success? And that
could be all kinds of things. Okay? I'
I've made other videos about um the
different types of books and how they're
linked to different purposes. Right?
Your your purpose could be building or
launching your personal brand. It could
be to bring in uh new clients for a
consulting offer. It could be to leave a
legacy to your friends and family. Or it
could be to share an idea. There are all
kinds of purposes, but it's important to
get really clear about the writer's
purpose because everything after this is
going to come down to the reader. So,
what does the writer want here? Write
down that goal because the second step
is to ask yourself, okay, who needs to
read this book in order for that goal to
come true. All right, so let's say for
example, you are a consultant in
business and you help leadership teams.
You have a consulting offer that helps
uh new managers become, you know,
exceptional CEOs. Great. So therefore,
who needs to read your book in order to
drive that outcome? in order for you to
get qualified leads into your consulting
practice. Well, that would be maybe new
managers, people who were newly promoted
to managerial positions who need uh some
quick advice for that. I need them to
read this book. All right. So, what do I
know about those people? Well, they're
short for time, right? They they don't
want a big 300page book that they're
going to have to sit down in an armchair
to read. They'd probably like something
that they could digest in an audio book
form. These are the kinds of questions
that you would ask yourself after you've
identified your goal. You then think
about who needs to read this book in
order for me to achieve that goal.
Right? And once you've got that person
in your sites, you need to pinpoint
their main problem or pain. Right? This
is going to organize the ideas that we
put in this book and the promise that we
put right there on the title. All right.
So, who is this person who is going to
help me achieve my goal? And what is
their current problem or pain? Because
once we have that pain in sight, we're
going to design the table of contents as
a bridge that helps them move from their
current situation to a solution to their
problem. So, if their problem is a
practical problem, then that table of
contents is going to show actions that
they can take that will fix that
problem. Now if it's a mindset problem,
if it's about the things that they
believe, then similarly we're going to
build a bridge from their current belief
set to the set of ideas that we would
like to replace them with. And finally,
after we have that bridge set in the
table of contents, that's when we
filter. Every story, every idea, every
example comes down to does it help the
reader solve that problem. It's why it's
really important to always start off
with this frame of what am I trying to
do? Who's the reader who can help me do
that? What's the what's the reader's
problem? And how can this book help the
reader solve that problem? It's really
important to have that frame in view
because that becomes the razor that we
use to decide what elements go into the
book. Right? You might have a great
story about your own spiritual journey
or whatever it is you want to talk
about, but if it doesn't help the reader
solve the problem, the promise that
you've got there right on the title,
then we cut it. And that's what
everybody in the reviews has been
saying. This book lost their focus. This
book is unfocused. Be it just kind of
meanders all over the place, right? It
makes a specific promise right there in
the title and it doesn't deliver because
it just goes down all these little side
roads that were interesting to Dan but
from the reader's perspective were
completely irrelevant. The other reason
why I wanted to get a clear sense of the
reader is because well again I don't
want to come at this book with my own
personal tastes or bias. That's really
not what editing is about. Editing is
about helping the writer identify their
goals and then reverse engineering the
needs and interests of the reader who
will help them achieve those goals. You
don't want to bring your own personal
bias into it. Maybe in the world of
fiction that would work but in the world
of this genre which is practical not
prescriptive non-fiction uh writing it's
not about what I think or you know some
arbitrary list of rules that all writing
should follow. It's about readers
specific readers and their problems and
interests. Books are tools and when you
write a book without a reader in mind
you don't have a book you have a diary.
Okay. When you write for a specific
reader and a specific problem, then what
you've done is written a useful book.
And useful books are the ones that get
finished, shared, and recommended. All
right. This third point is all about
structure. So, as one reviewer writes,
great intent, but everything feels all
over the place. No structure, no thread.
I kept forgetting what I'd read 10
minutes earlier. And that review
basically sums up the next big issue.
Chaos. absolute mayhem. There's no
sequence to your thoughts. Now, in the
biz, this is what we call coherence and
cohesion. But one way that I like to
teach this in my non-fiction writing
seminar is to ask students to picture
their writing as one of these 3D cube
puzzles, you know. So, you can look at
the individual pieces of the puzzle and
that's one level of resolution. At the
micro level, you've got these individual
pieces, different shapes, and every
piece has to connect to the next one to
create this larger macro structure. If
one block is off, then the whole cube
loses its shape and coherence. And so,
it's the same with sentences and
paragraphs. One line might be fine on
its own, but if it doesn't connect to
what comes before it, and if it doesn't
set up what comes next, then the reader
feels lost. Sentences work together to
form paragraphs. Paragraphs work
together to form sections. Sections work
together to form chapters. And chapters
come together to form books. And if
these pieces don't work together, then
the text turns into a scattered mess
instead of a single cohesive message.
And that's what these reviewers are
getting at. They like the ideas and they
like Dan, but the book didn't hold
together. And I can't blame them. Now
sometimes writers resist this idea of
structure because they feel like well
they take some of the tips that they
learned in fiction writing which is a
lot more um exploratory and unplanned.
It's what Stephen King calls uh pancers
instead of planners, right? They so they
want to take the elements of fiction
writing and bring it into non-fiction.
But when you don't work with and you
know it's and it's not even such a bad
thing like if if you just want to
develop your writing practice and
explore your ideas, I actually do think
it's it's nice to be able to write in an
unstructured way. But when it comes to
compiling your ideas into a book, it's
important to think in terms of
structures because when these pieces
don't cohhere with each other, any
piece, whether you know this sentence
doesn't cohhere with this paragraph or
this paragraph isn't talking to the
other ones in this section or if if you
lose the coherence at any level of
resolution, then what happens is you
start to make these gaps. There are
these gaps between your ideas, right?
They're not linking with each other.
This idea isn't linking backwards to
what came before it and it's not leaning
forwards to set up what's about to come.
And so you start getting these orphaned
ideas that are just floating around as
we saw it a lot in Dan's book. Each like
you could pick any paragraph and I would
have to say it's fine. Like okay, yeah,
it's an interesting idea. It starts to
fall apart though when readers ask the
question, "What does this have to do
with practical life advice? How does
this turn me into a one-person
business?" But see, what happens is
readers don't just allow these gaps to
happen. Well, if they skip over the gap,
then it means they're not reading it. In
linguistics, we call these Graces
maxims. So don't worry too much about
it. But just understand that everybody
who speaks language automatically
assumes that the your ideas cohhere with
each other. That there's a reason that
you're putting this sentence after that
sentence. And there's a reason an
intentional reason why this paragraph is
coming after that one. Even if you don't
intend it, readers can only read
assuming that you intended it. It's it's
like an underlying maxim of language.
And so therefore, if your ideas are not
coherent with each other, then they're
filling in the gaps. And now the reader
is doing this work. The reader is
thinking, "Huh, well, I guess this
intelligent writer, you know,
intentionally put this idea after that.
So there must be some link between them.
I must be the stupid one cuz I don't see
how I don't see the sequence between
these ideas." And it just becomes a
mess. And so either they start
misinterpreting, you know, inventing
reasons that you put one after the other
or they just start thinking they get
frustrated is basically they start
having to work too hard to kind of
invent these links between your ideas
and it just becomes a total mess. All
right, so here's a quick thought
experiment to show you the purpose of
the sequence of your ideas. All right,
so it'd be great if you close your eyes.
You probably won't, but I'm going to ask
you to close your eyes because I'm going
to ask you to picture something here.
I'm going to give you three colors and I
just want you to see those colors. All
right. So, you ready for this? Red,
yellow,
blue. All right. Now, if you're actually
playing along, you saw those colors in
sequence. Now, we're going to do it just
one more time, and we're going to flip
the order. So, close your eyes and
picture these colors: blue,
yellow,
red. All right, open your eyes. Now, if
you actually played along here, what you
might have noticed is how the shading of
the word yellow shifts. All right? So,
in the first set, I said red, yellow,
blue. So, red comes first, and when red
comes first, the yellow seems closer to
orange. But in the second one, when blue
comes first, the yellow feels closer to
green. It's the same word, but it has a
different meaning and different visual
impression because the context changed.
So ideas work exactly the same way.
Context first, meaning second. If
there's no context, like the word
literally doesn't mean anything. It
doesn't mean anything on its own. Words
only gain their significance in
relationship to each other. So keeping
that lesson about context in mind,
here's how you can build structure into
your writing. No matter what level of
discourse you're working at, so let's
think about paragraphs, but this also
extends to sections, chapters, and even
the book. Talking about the introduction
here, no matter what, at the start of a
unit of discourse, what you want is an
index section. So, in the context of a
paragraph, that's probably going to be
the first sentence of a paragraph. And
it expands into larger language units,
you know, the larger the unit of
discourse we're talking about. But
again, in the context of a paragraph,
let's just talk about the first
sentence. So you want that sentence to
set the high-level idea right up front
and then later in the rest of the
section you're going to unpack it with
examples and evidence. Another good
principle for structure is to remember
that a paragraph is the unit of one
idea. One paragraph, one simple thought.
So this is something I usually do with
clients when we're looking at their
their drafts. I say, "Great. In this
paragraph or in this section, I want you
to underline the main point. What's the
main point? What's the one idea that you
want the reader to walk away with? Right
now, if you can't do that, then you need
to rework the paragraph. If you can do
that, then we move that statement up to
the index position and then we rewrite
the rest of it to kind of follow. Third,
this is nothing you didn't get from your
high school grammar class, but it's
really important to use transitions.
Phrases like in addition, by contrast,
for example. These these phrases are
important because they help readers see
the relationships between your
sentences. And if you don't label those
relationships, then again, you're asking
the reader to fill in the gaps. The
reader's asking themsself, why is the
writer putting this sentence after that
sentence? So, we should signal it.
Unless it's like painfully obvious, we
should help the reader as much as
possible to fill in those gaps. Fourth,
another tip from your high school
writing class, but again it's useful,
which is to write with an outline. Just
like the book should have a table of
contents, your chapter needs a table of
ideas. And finally, think in fractals.
Okay, so I just gave you this pattern
for a paragraph to have the index
section at the top and the discussion
section come after that. But that
expands just like any fractal pattern
that expands to all levels of
resolution. So try to keep this in mind.
Another good fractal pattern to keep in
mind is uh what's called the uneven U.
That comes from an academic named Eric
Hyatt, but it's really useful in the
context of most non-fiction. Um, which
is to say, you want the idea that you
introduce at the start of a section to
be more specific than where the section
ends. I could probably do another video
on this one, but generally the idea here
is that you want the paragraph to end at
a more general level of resolution than
where it began. So, you want to begin
the paragraph or the section with a um
an index statement. It's sometimes known
as a claim or a topic sentence. And you
want that to move gradually down uh to
more and more specific information until
you ultimately come to a piece of
evidence. That could be an anecdote, an
example, um, or some data that you're
using or a quote. Um, but then after
that, you don't just want to drop it.
You want to bring it back into your web
of interpretation, moving back up to a
more general, uh, level of resolution.
And the point of Eric Hyatt's uneven you
is that you want to end at a more
general level than where you began
because that gives your paragraphs and
your sections a kind of momentum, right?
you're you're not just ending where you
began, but you're kind of pushing off of
that into the larger context of the
overall section. But the point here is
that you want to think of these units of
discourse according to these fractal
patterns. The pattern of development
that you use at the paragraph level
should mirror that which you use at the
level of the section, that of the
chapter, that of the book. That's what
gives your book a sense of cohesion. And
ultimately what we're talking about here
is that readers want the writer to guide
them on a journey. They don't want to
have to wade their way through a pile of
paragraphs. So whatever patterns and and
tips from this section you've taken,
ultimately what you want to do is to
give them rails that they can ride on.
You want to take them on a guided
journey and make it feel easy for them
to get your ideas so that even your more
complex ideas can feel effortless to
follow. Right? This last point comes
down to voice. So, one reviewer writes,
"Every sentence doesn't need to be an
apherism, Dan. Write with more
humanity." Another reviewer says,
"Calling your ideas teachings feels
pompous. He sounds like a sage guru
talking down to us." These reviewers
weren't rejecting Dan's ideas. They were
rejecting the voice on the page. And
this is an important idea to understand
is that there's a difference between the
voice of the writer and the voice that's
there on the page, right? On the page. I
mean, I don't really know if this is
like profound or trit to say, but it
when I first understood this idea, it
really did a lot for me. So I I hope you
take it and I hope it doesn't sound too
obvious to say that there is a
difference between Dan Co, the guy that
we see on the YouTube videos and the
author on the page, the Danco that
exists within the representational space
of the text on the page. It's not the
flesh and blood Dan. It's a persona
that's made of sentences and language
choices. And based on those language
choices, if the persona feels arrogant
or preachy, then no matter how much they
like your YouTube channel, they're still
going to bail on the book because they
hate the guy that's in the page. So, one
fast way to sound preachy is overusing
the word you. All right? So, this is I'm
not about to get into one of these
grammar rules about never use personal
pronouns. You know, your high school
English teacher might have told you
never say I or never say you. that it's
not really what I'm getting at here,
okay? But there there is a there there's
a way that your language choices
represent your relationship to the
reader, right? Based on your language
choices, you're crafting a persona there
on the page. And so that's one element.
That's that's the author persona. But if
that author persona is always saying you
you you
well, depending on how you use it, it's
probably not going to be very helpful.
it's probably going to come across as
condescending and arrogant. And that's
what a lot of these reviewers are
saying. All right. So, one way that I
like to teach this in my non-fiction
writing class is to ask my students to
picture the text like a stage. All
right? So, you you can imagine if you're
sitting in the audience at a musical or
a a theater performance, um there are
these scenes and each paragraph or each
section could be like a scene. Now in a
scene on any stage performance there are
only going to be a limited number of
characters who come onto the stage.
Usually only two or three probably at
most four right different characters
will come on the stage and actually have
any meaningful role. Why is that? Well
more than that and it becomes kind of
hard to follow. There's too much
happening too many you know things being
said and and relationships to keep track
of. So that's why plays and performances
are organized into these scenes. And I
think it's helpful to think of
paragraphs and sections in terms of
these scenes. And so if that's what it
is, if a paragraph is like a scene, then
you would have to think of whatever goes
in the subject position as being an
actor on the stage, right? Whatever is
in the subject position, you know, when
it comes down to subject, verb, object,
that is the actor who is saying
something or doing something, right?
It's it's the thing that performs the
action of the verb. And whatever is in
the subject position is getting the
spotlight. It's getting the viewer's
attention. It's getting the reader's
attention, right? So, the reader is
looking at whatever is in the spotlight.
And so I think whenever you keep putting
you, which is not intentional, like it
it's actually just kind of something
that happens when writers aren't paying
attention to um because it it's it's not
like he's not writing an advice column.
It's not one of these like agony and
like what should I do columns. Oh well,
you should do this. No, like that's not
what the book is. Um, generally it's
just when writers are working with an
editor and they're not thinking about
how they build their sentences. It kind
of comes across as Dan is like leaving a
note to himself. He's always like, "You
need to lock in and you need to focus on
like he he's not really talking to the
reader." But of course, that's the way
that it feels whenever we read it. So,
if you follow this metaphor, then
putting you in the subject position is
like putting the reader onto the stage,
right? The reader is supposed to be
there in the audience and they're
watching these ideas play out and
they're learning things from watching
the drama, but now we're breaking the
fourth wall and we're like, you have to
do this and now the reader is on the
stage. I don't know if that exactly
tracks, but the thing to understand here
is that by constantly putting you in the
subject position, the it makes the
reader feel like they're being lectured,
right? They're there because they want
to learn about these ideas. They want to
learn about the, you know, the ideas in
the book. And the way to do that is to
put the idea in the subject position and
let the reader relax. All right, so
here's just a quick example. In one
chapter, Dan writes, "You let your brain
form grooves." Right? So that's what I
mean. He's not really talking to you. He
He might be talking to himself or it
might just be a lazy way to build that
sentence, but he's not trying to make a
point about you. He's trying to talk
about neuroplasticity or something like
that. And so another way of writing that
which would be more palatable to the
readers might be that the brain forms
grooves over time. All right, that puts
the brain in the subject position. Now
the brain is receiving the spotlight.
And we see that it forms grooves.
Alternatively, if Dan wanted to
emphasize the grooves, then it could be
grooves are formed in the brain over
time, right? There are different ways of
doing it, but the point is that in most
cases, you probably shouldn't be
building your sentence with you in the
subject position. It's kind of rude. You
know, we observe this rule in languages,
too. Like in um certainly in Korean,
it's uh it's considered rude to use you
uh as the subject of a sentence. Like
technically the the the word in Korean
for you is dangshin. But yeah, it's kind
of rude and direct to make a sentence
around dangin. Usually they would use a
passive form to avoid naming uh the
listener in the sentence. So, whatever
the point is that uh try to build your
sentence without you in the subject
position because it just comes across as
finger wagging. So, to fix that, well,
go through your section and just
underline every time you say the word
you. I mean, look at this typical page
from Dan Co's book. It's just filled
with references to you. Now, not saying
it's universally a rule that you can
never say you, but how about you ask
yourself like, do I really need to say
you this many times? Right. Getting away
from the point about you. How how else
can we avoid being preachy? All right.
Well, it's helpful to use qualifiers,
right? Words like might, can, often, or
in some cases. Um, this kind of, you
know, modulates your claims and so that
you don't come across as too arrogant or
too self-confident. Um, this is a matter
of balance. I I also don't really like
it when writers are too hedgy and and
they're not kind of strong and assertive
enough in uh their writing. So, it takes
balance, but that's what working with an
editor is all about. And when you don't
work on an editor, then you can create
an author persona that seems way too
cocky and way too sure of himself and
really turns readers off. So, one way to
control that is to be careful. You know,
use qualifiers, modulate your claims.
Okay? As I've been saying, lead with the
topic. like try to make the idea the
star of each sentence. I've made this
point about not putting you so much in
the subject position, but in general,
it's just good for writers to think
about what is in the subject position
because it's not always you. Sometimes
there are dummy subjects like there, you
know, there is um or um it, you know,
which doesn't actually refer to
anything. Uh again, that's not always
wrong. But when writers are not
conscious about the psychological effect
of the subject position, then they can
their pros can be rather hard or
uncomfortable to follow. And fourth,
just try to be intentional about the
persona that you craft there on the
page. Of course, writers feel like, "No,
this is my voice. This came from me."
But in fact, it's not you. There's not
the totality of you. even though you
wrote everything, the reader doesn't
have you there as context when they're
interpreting your work. So, it really is
the the the character in your book
really is a separate entity. And so,
your word choices, your language
choices, the way you choose to arrange
your ideas really matters when it comes
to the impression that you're going to
make on your readers. So, all of this
comes down to tone. And if you can
really nail tone, readers will stay with
you because what you want is to sound
like a partner and not a preacher. At
the end of the day, Dan Co's book failed
not because he's a bad writer, but
because he wrote for the wrong genre. He
wanted to write an ideas book, but he
sold it as a practical problem-solving
book, which it's not. But little did Dan
know that there are more genres to
choose from. And if you'd like to write
a non-fiction book of your own, then
watch this video next because it's going
to show you six types of books that each
have a different purpose. Whether you're
trying to bring in more leads, share an
idea, leave a legacy by telling your
story, or position yourself as a thought
leader and launch a personal brand. So,
be sure to go check it out.
[Music]